if a government can't provide the core
basic services it's failed in its
mission after an injury ended his
14-year career as a police officer Pete
constant decided to bring some law and
order to local government and ran for
City Council where he sat as a member
for eight years and became a proponent
of pension reform the result was measure
B which restructured the retirement
benefits of San Jose city employees and
was passed by a large majority in one of
the most liberal regions in the state
Pete recently sat down with reason TV to
talk about the fight to save his city
from financial disaster and what other
localities can do to adopt reform our
city had been in many years of budget
deficits and there were many years
coming in the future and I just thought
that the financial decisions had been
terribly made and so I really wanted to
focus on that and pensions were a part
of it but not the driving factor it was
once I got into office and I started
asking questions and learning more and
serving on one of the pension funds
initially and then ultimately both of
them and getting trained in them and
finding out what was really under the
surface and this huge problem that
people were not even aware of let alone
talking about how did it get to the
point where it was just so bad in a
10-year period from the year 2001 to the
year 2011 the city's responsibility for
pension contributions went from
approximately 72 to 74 million dollars a
year to two hundred and forty five
million dollars a year so a quarter of
our operating budget was going just to
make pension contributions so we had
really one area to look at here's the
problem and then it was how do we find
out within this circle a pension what
are the driving factors in there and to
do that we had to do a lot of
investigation a lot of Education I had
to learn a lot about pensions what were
some of the residents going through in
your area when you had these cops like
this just mounting eyes well in San Jose
it had gotten so bad that it was evident
to almost every single resident we had
built a brand-new police station over a
hundred million dollars brand-new
police station with a fence around it
because we could not afford to move
people and do it we had four brand new
libraries throughout the city that were
the same they were built ready to go had
all the equipment books in them but they
had a fence around because we couldn't
afford to put employees at him we
couldn't afford to maintain the roads
anymore because we had to continually
cut back
we went from a workforce of over 7500
employees to just about just over 5,000
employees so severe reduction of people
to provide services to the residents so
it was impossible for a resident to go
through their normal everyday life and
not feel the impact of the cuts that we
had to make what did you guys do in the
city to kind of help scale back some of
these costs well I think it's important
to know that we did more than just our
one pension reform vote that most people
know us for it was a multi-year process
we started off with some big things that
were simpler like changing the
governance structure of our pension
board making sure that we had more
people who had no conflicts of interest
serving and some expertise serving on
our pension board so we could get better
decisions being made we also had
provisions in our Charter that had
minimum pension benefits written into
the city charter which a charter for
cities like the Constitution you have to
follow it so first we went to the voters
and said we have a problem we want to
find a solution but we can't do it
because of this charter provision work
with us approved taking these minimums
out of the Charter so that we can
negotiate and come up with a change in
our pensions and we'll bring that back
to you for approval what that did is
that gave us multiple bites of the Apple
multiple times to engage with the public
talked to him about what we were doing
highlight the issues that we had we
completely changed our budget process so
that as we talked about balancing our
budget we had discussions about the
driving factors and we were able to
connect the dots between these rising
costs and these cut services so that the
residents could see and understand in
simple language what was happening you
know as far as the public looking at
this and dealing with the unions and
other groups did you feel like they both
we're on the same page there it was a
mixed bag to be honest there were a lot
of people in the community that just
didn't know they didn't know we had this
problem they didn't understand the whole
pension concept because it's a pretty
complicated system that public agencies
have so we had to do a lot of Education
but once we were able to bring it down
to an understandable level and break it
down into component parts and talk to
people and make comparisons to what's
from what's happening in the financial
numbers to what's happening in everyday
life the people really began to get it
with the employee unions it was very
difficult the discussions at first we
put together a task force and it was a
structural budget deficit elimination
task force and we had people sit around
table to engage people in discussions
and we had our union leaders sit there
with their arms folded and not willing
to have a discussion one of the union
leaders had an op-ed piece printed in
the Mercury News that basically said we
don't have a problem it was a stickier
head-in-the-sand
let's just wait for this problem to go
away because you'd hear many times well
the Dow is going to recover and our
problem will go away but we all know
that the doubt recovered and our problem
hasn't gone away fact it's bigger than
it was before so we had a lot of
contention with our employees but we sat
we created another taskforce we had more
meetings we went through the meet and
confer process we went through the seal
Beach negotiations we had a number of
discussions we never ultimately were
able to get to a point where they agreed
with us very contentious we had
picketing going on we had all kinds of
protests and things like that to draw
attention to what they felt was unfair
treatment or scapegoating that we were
blaming the problem on the employees
which we weren't doing well we were
actually trying to do and we try to
remind us we're trying to protect you
especially in your retirement years make
sure you have this benefit that by the
way you've been paying into just like we
have and so we never really got to a
resolution with the unions but we knew
we had a problem that we had to carry
forward so we took it to the voters made
our case with the voters and the voters
resoundingly agreed with us that this
something that we had to deal with how
would you say reform is working in just
implementing the new tier for new
employees the city is already saving
over 20 million dollars per year for two
consecutive years so we've realized over
40 million dollars in savings
now that pales in comparison to the 65
or more million per year that we will
save once we are able to completely
implement but those 20 million dollars
each year have gone a long way towards
restoring services so we've been able to
open every one of those close libraries
we've been able to start repairing our
streets we've been able to do a number
of things that we weren't able to do
just two short years ago what do you say
to critics of your plan that are maybe
looking to you guys as a reason to not
do reform I think it's important that we
point out what's fact from fiction
you will hear repeated over and over
about the auto control crime rate in San
Jose when in fact our crime rate is down
our violent crime and homicides in
particular are down in San Jose and it's
just not the City Council saying that
you can look at the police department
either there are statistics or the
statistics that they report to the FBI
our crime is going down and has been
going down so so where is the
misinformation coming from well people
who are against pension reform will
create whatever stories they need to
help their case and we just did a survey
of a number of residents and even though
crime is going down in San Jose the
perception of crime is going up and I
think that's by a number of reasons one
is it has been repeated so often by the
police officers the firefighters and the
union leaders that people believe it
because they trust these people these
are people who hold positions of trust
in our community and they are saying it
and the residents have no reason not to
believe it so it's our job as a city to
correct those facts as we go on so as
more counties and cities are looking at
reform what are some of the takeaways
from your experience in San Jose that
you can tell other reformers I think the
first thing is the elected officials in
these cities and counties have to
educate themselves many of them don't
even know what their pension system
consists of let alone what obligations
they have and in order to get the right
answers you need
to know what questions to ask and many
elected officials just don't have the
expertise nor the time to gain the
expertise to ask those questions so I
would say if if you're not sure you have
a problem or if you know you have a
problem you need to reach out to people
who have dealt with this to talk to them
so you can find out what questions you
need to ask then avail yourself to a
number of the resources out there like
the resources and the pension reform
toolkit that reason has to look at how
you can address the issue there's not a
one-size-fits-all solution to this
because there are so many different
varieties of pension plans so many
different pension benefits that you've
got to find out what's going to work for
your community click below to see more
from recent TV and subscribe for all of
our latest videos